we'll play the game again
he's kind of hit my check
uh yesterday's drill had an exercise
like he's lifting up remember you
remember okay and I I matched that and
uh
get the adhesion okay but in the game
you're gonna do some of that and some
adhesion
you're gonna do some Coq projections so
you're going to do a higher young value
but we're going to aim it into his uh
Tandon okay
and then you're going to do some
following some just basic trapping
skills you have to combine all of them
okay because he's attempting to get off
of an adhesion he's trying he's
attempting to get out of the Ikea
adhesion as he's trying to strike his
Target and he's trying to free himself
from a Coq projection so you have to do
some basic trapping skills okay all
right so he's uh trying to touch my
chest
trying to do we go
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
so there's something
to understand
about the game
um that it is a game
that it has rules okay
so uh for example
uh anchor your base that is deep in this
there you go don't let me push you over
right
okay
um
what this is going to do is like we've
fallen out of the game rule set and this
is this always happens with games
whenever you make rules whenever you
make context we start to milk the rule
set as we Chase what we consider victory
in the game versus the training thing
okay
um and all you have to do is uh change
sides and you'll notice that
um while you become a little more
difficult to project do you understand
uh you become so you over uh how I want
to say this you over stabilize in the
game and which is fine when you're not
uh being hit back because Mobility is
not there okay so we'll switch roles
okay and that'll be enough to to expose
it
okay
you see
so you as your as you're doing the drill
you have as you're the UK
you don't want to get caught in the game
as a winning losing game it's more like
a game that has rules so if you're
playing Monopoly
you play Within the rules you don't just
take everyone's money and go I win does
that make sense so
as uh you're trying to do this
you're also giving the spinal
displacement energy you get that
as opposed to when connect and hear
what am I do you feel like if you go off
really fast go off really fast no you're
gonna go off really fast get connection
again there we are here we are right you
see I have spinal displacement energy
move out of the way really fast and be
safe
come back I feel you connect to my
center right there's my scent there's my
center and you feel it okay now now go
off really fast
see I was never really finally
displacing do you see that so as you're
playing the game my goal is to keep
giving that energy and so that you don't
train yourself
incorrectly
for which I wouldn't even call grounding
it's a bracing angle so uh don't let me
project you again don't let me project
you again okay don't let me project you
with keep your extension like you were
don't let me project you okay now
uh Dawn you're coming up you're coming
up come on come on don't let It Go Don't
Let There you go okay there it is right
there stay there don't move
and you can see
this little Arc right here
okay
so I'll exaggerate it so you you can see
come in the back so you can see
you see here
okay as opposed to
here
you go look at that
see
so when I go like this
I get a bracing angle that's what that
that's what a lot of Aikido people do is
they Point their pelvis down
and a lot of tension and stress goes in
the back you see that you get that okay
so again try to push me and I'm just
bracing against that and say that you
should feel that you've just generated a
huge amount of tension all through here
all through here if you see and in that
box okay so don't let me do it again do
what you were doing before
okay
and don't let me don't let me project
you race there you go you feel that
tension stay there stay there nope don't
go off I don't want you to go off okay
do you feel the tension in your all
through here okay so that that you don't
want to do it's not that it's not
projectable but it's not training so for
example here's here's the block and when
you watch the video you'll see me just
circle it okay
or you go around you go around it get
off of this one get off that one hit the
chest get off of it okay so when you go
around when you get off then I circled
it again you see okay or you pull back
go off of it you see and then I follow
you see and I'm in here okay and then I
would do it again you would brace again
you see and then we have
another way you get it it's not that
I I liked it myself because it trains me
higher but it's training you lower okay
got it all right okay